to sports now the golden knights we're
back in action for the second time this
season
vegas took on anaheim with a whole new
look don treach has our golden knight
highlights tonight john
that's right gold is the ultimate it's a
symbol of strength power wealth
and treasure people cross the globe to
find it but rarely are successful in
vegas
more than anywhere gold represents
winning just ask the anaheim ducks
they were orange and issuing a code red
look at the mark andre fleury fit
oh yes the knights had a treasure in net
ducks thought they had a key to the
treasure early with an odd man rush
maximum control he's going to score his
third goal of the season
already but more importantly the
go-ahead one in this game fleury kept
vegas in the game he just needed an
ounce of offense 90 seconds left
marchessault finds william carlson for
the equalizer while bill makes the bench
go wild one to one we go to overtime
from the opening face-off golden knights
roar down the ice mark stone finds
max pacharetti who scorches the back of
the net 2-1
vegas emphatically wins and with drama